découvrir les outils utilisés par les
sportifs de haut niveau pour améliorer
ses performances professionnelles
c'était le but de cette conférence
imaginé par le centre des jeunes
dirigeants d'entreprise dans les
yvelines
une association qui regroupe une
trentaine d'adhérents près d'echallens
un champion parce qu'il doit se préparer
beaucoup ça s'improvise pas un business
et donc l'idée c'est effectivement de
fer parallèle entre le sport les
dirigeants pour travailler sur tout ce
qui est préparation pour être au top le
jour j
atteindre un objectif aller plus loin ou
encore savoir rebondir des valeurs
communes au monde de l'entreprise et au
monde sportif
le rôle du coach s'est toujours gardé
les yeux fixés pour moi sur l'objectif
ensuite c'est ensemble avec l'équipe
qu'on définit l'action qu'on peut
dérouler pour y arriver on parle souvent
du bien-être en entreprise
la question c'est comment optimiser ses
compétences personnelles pour pouvoir
rester à son meilleur niveau
développer son potentiel des faire les
choses avec le moins de fatigue possible
à la fois mentale et physique
parmi les intervenants le septuple
champion du monde de vélo sur piste
pour françois pervis le monde de
l'entreprise a beaucoup à apprendre du
monde du sport de haut niveau qu'il faut
savoir se poser les bonnes questions il
faut savoir optimiser les forçant les
forces en présence savoir aussi bien
s'entourer pour pour créer une équipe
autour de soi et et pour pouvoir a soit
faire les chiffres une entreprise et moi
à gagner gagner me médaille d'or après
les jeux olympiques à tokyo en 2020 le
cycliste a déjà préparé sa reconversion
avec la création d'une société
preuve que le monde du sport et le monde
de l'entreprise sont deux chemins
parallèles qui peuvent bel et bien se
rejoindre